và kìm chát tự tế, phía sau, khu dân cư, xuất hiện, các vết nất trên sần rồi.
Cú vực này nằm gần một khai nước lớn, phía trên và đổi cao.
Trong được kiện tiếp tục có mưa, đất đả ngâm nước,
Wiggle Sát Chua dùng, khu dân cư đổi đánh giá, mức cao.
Ngay trong tối mới chỉ thả tạm, cán vô sả nả tấu tình diện biên.
Phu hợp cùng công an, dân quân, cùng cứ lượng tại chố, đã hữu chợn người dân dí chuyển người vợp tại sạm.
Đến hai mình bà dự bà mê phó cùng ngay và mộ mối vau hộ với sống mình nhìn khẩu.
đã được đưa ra khỏi khu vực có mê cơ xa lời.
Châu mắt cao hồ dân được bổ chi ở tạm tại nhàng người thân
và cao hồ dân được bổ lân cân.
Chính quyết địa phương tuy tiền đương người dân ra khỏi của mùi yệm.
Lông thời hỗ trợ dí chuyển những tại sản thiết yêu,
có ra trị và các phương tiện bật nuôi dây dây chuyển.
Như xem mấy châu, bỏ, theo quý bán dân sả nả tấu,
việc bổ chi ở lâu ra trung người dân và phương án sử li khu vực có mấy cơ xa lời
sẽ được tình tóan sau khi tiếp tục khảo sát, đánh giảm ước động vi hiểm.
Ui bán dân tình địa biển cũng đã mang hành công điện yêu cầu,
có thể phương ra sóa, những khu vực có mấy cơ xảy ra thân tay.
Bổ chi nước lượng trực cạnh dưới tại các vị trí xung yêu,
tăng cường cạnh bảo chức tiếp đến người dân và chủ động tổ chất dây dồi khi có mất an tóan.